TED SANDER: Hello.
Welcome to Upgrading the
Engine Mid-flight-- How Google
Improves its Web Apps
Without Downtime.
I'm Ted Sander.
This is Paul Rohde.
And we're going to be your
guides on this journey.
So flashback, 2013
Google I/O, a developer
is watching all the
sessions from his computer,
learning about Polymer,
about Dart, about Angular,
about removing jank
from his web apps,
about improving the render
speed of his application.
And he just gets really
excited about all
this cool new
technology they can use.
The speakers make it seem
so easy and so powerful.
It just excites him and
gets him very excited again.
So during his
downtime, he starts
using all this new technology,
and it's easy and wonderful
and just makes him love
programming again, right?
It's just fun to
do and everything
just simple and powerful.
And he can build great apps
using all this technology.
But every morning, he
wakes up, gets in his car
and drives to work, sits
down at his computer
and is just frustrated.
He makes a line of
code chains, takes him
about 15 to 20 minutes
to see it on the screen.
He's about five levels
away from the DOM.
He doesn't even remember
what it looks like anymore.
He's hardly touching HTML.
It's in this other
language that's
being translated a couple
times before it actually
gets to the render.
He can't use all the cool new
tools in Chrome and everything
else because the
app's just huge,
and he can't even do anything.
And it's just so
frustrating, he just
doesn't want to deal with it.
So he has this
crazy idea, right?
What if he could have
that excellent environment
that he has at home?
What if he could bring
it and actually do
the same things at work?
What if he could
get all the power
from all those cool
technologies that he worked with
and just make development fun
again, even at work, right?
So he goes to his co-worker, and
he tells him this crazy idea.
And they start
working through it.
And there's just so much code.
There's so much legacy code.
They have all these tools
that they can use with.
The problem just
seems impossible.
It just seems so hard.
They don't even
know where to start.
Where do you even begin
on this journey, right?
It just seems like
it's unattainable.
And that developer is me, right?
And I don't work for some
government contractor.
I don't work for a
bank or something
like that or some other
old school system.
I work for Google, right?
The people who developed all
this cool new technology.
Even at Google we
have these problems.
We have these problems of these
old systems and these older
applications that we've made.
We don't magically get
all the new Polymer stuff
just because we snapped our
fingers, and we invented it.
It doesn't magically become into
every single one of our apps,
right?
We still have to day-to-day
deal with upgrading and making
it happen and making all
this new technology go
into our apps.
And this is like, and I'm sure
many of you in the audience
can relate, right?
You're sitting there.
You're learning about
all this new technology,
and you're going, there's no way
I can use that at work, right?
There's just so much work
that would need to be done,
I don't even know
where to start.
where to begin, right?
Or maybe perhaps
you have the luxury
of having a complete
green field system.
You can start
everything from scratch,
and you can do
whatever you want.
But how do you make
sure that in one I/O,
that in three I/Os, that in five
I/Os, and six years later, how
can you ensure
that you, too, can
use all the new technology
that's coming out then?
What kind of practices can you
do to make sure that happens?
So our goal for today is to
give you some of the challenges
that we went through in trying
to upgrade our apps and some
of the strategies that we had
so that we could make it happen.
We'll give you some
examples on how we did that,
but the more important is
the strategy and the tools
that we tried to enforce to
make sure that we could make
this upgrade much more easier,
more like a walk in a park
and less like
scaling a mountain.
PAUL ROHDE: Wow.
I've never ever had to
deal with that ever.
TED SANDER: You're lucky.
PAUL ROHDE: You
guys have all seen
this happen if you've
been in development
for any amount of time.
You've seen small applications
grow into large applications.
You've seen these challenges.
As systems get larger,
they strain the edges
of what you can actually do.
The technology
start to break down
as your applications get bigger.
And just maintaining
code after a while
slowly gets to the
point where you just
don't want to do it anymore.
So today we're going to
talk through, like Ted said,
what we've gone through, some
strategy we've been through.
And we're going to cover
it in four major areas.
First, we're going to talk about
large applications and just
any application.
We're going to talk about
how we break them apart
into smaller pieces.
We have huge applications,
and lots and lots of people
work on them, so how do
we take 100 engineers
and distribute it across
a single front end?
So we'll talk about that.
Second, we're going
to talk about testing
because if you're
building a large front
end or any large
application, you
want to make sure
that it continues
to work day after day.
You may release it on
day one, and it may work.
But how do you make sure that
it continues to work on day two,
on day three, and release
number five, ten, 15,
all the way out through the
life cycle of the application.
So we're going to
talk about testing,
what we do, how we do it, what
we found that's important.
So we're going to
talk about that.
Third, we want to make the
front end engineers productive.
Like Ted said, you want to take
the development environment
that you have at
home, the ability
to go and hack stuff up
and build something really
quickly, and then be able
to take that to work.
So we want to show
you how to take
that to work, what we've
done to make front end
engineers productive,
and the tools that we use
to pick frameworks and
tools that work for us.
Fourth and finally, we're
going to tie this all together.
We ended up with
Dart, but we're going
to talk about how the
language takes everything
that we're going to talk about
in the first three sections,
and how it ties it all together.
And then we're going to wrap it
up, and then we'll be all done.
TED SANDER: So this
is great, Paul.
I mean, but how in the world
are we ever going to start?
We have hundreds of engineers,
millions of lines of code.
It's just this huge, large app.
How are we ever going to begin
to start porting this over
to the new language?
PAUL ROHDE: It's
a great question.
We have huge front
ends at Google.
These are not small,
little blog pages.
We have applications that
have over a million lines
of front end code.
That's a lot.
Not only that, we have hundreds
of engineers working on them.
Now you'll see these
strains regardless
of the size of the project
or the number of people
you have working
on them, but just
imagine how hard it is to deal
with a code base of that size
and have that many engineers.
Now take that, and release your
front end every single week.
Think about that for a second.
That's a hard
problem to deal with.
As applications get
bigger, you have
to avoid this place where
your applications can just
start imploding on themselves.
You want to avoid this.
So we have a strategy.
We want to divide
and conquer our apps.
This is kind of what our
application looked like.
You have one big front
end, one JavaScript binary,
that has lots of
little sub-pieces.
And this is the problem
because if you have something
like this, where
every piece talks
in different parts
of the app, it's
hard to take a single
piece, pull it out, and work
on it in isolation.
So what do we do?
We had to do something
for this because we
needed to be able to have
all these engineers be
productive and
actually build things.
So we took it, and
we split it up.
All right, so in
this case-- and this
is not the only way we can
do it-- but in our case,
we built the message bus.
Very small, very simple.
It was just one little
piece of JavaScript
that let us pass messages
between other applications
on the page.
Now I guess a little context
is the front end that we're
talking about is all
a single application.
It's a single page, but we broke
it up into smaller sub-apps,
and each app talks to the other
apps through this message bus.
What this allowed
us to do, because we
had separate
JavaScript binaries,
is we can now replace any
single application individually.
A team of developers can work
on one single application
without having to deal with
a lot of the interactions
of the other pieces.
It lets us version things.
It lets teams release
things on different dates.
How many of you have sat back
and had to everybody coordinate
for the same release?
Having 200 engineers or even
100 engineers or even 10,
just getting them all to get
their code in so that you
can actually release
something is really hard.
So being able to have
smaller sub-teams that
release independently and
develop their own features,
and it can all work together
in one cohesive way is
really, really powerful.
So it's this idea of
one simple interface.
In our case, this was
really, really powerful.
Having a single point of
failure and a single place
where everything coordinates
was really powerful.
Now, globals are
generally bad so you
don't want to do this all
the time, but in this case,
it enabled us to do so
many other things that
were really valuable.
So that's that.
And my slides are
being wonderful.
Here's an example.
We got some concrete
code examples.
Just we have a global context,
which has a message bus in it,
and a simple send and listen.
In our case, we used
just JavaScript maps
with string variables
and then just passed
them back and forth.
Very simple, all
done by convention,
but again, it was something
that was very powerful
and enabled us to do
a lot of new things.
So this is cool.
So you can take your app,
and you can build it.
And you can break it
apart into small pieces.
And this is good regardless
of the application
that you're building.
But if you do this,
all of a sudden,
your applications have a lot
of code they need to share.
So Ted, how are we going
to deal with this problem?
We want to be able to
share all this code,
but we don't want to duplicate
it and write it all over again.
TED SANDER: Yeah,
it's a good question.
I mean, you have all
these different apps.
They're written in
different languages.
There's configuration
between them.
There's the APIs that all
need to talk similarly.
How in the world are we going
to make this happen across
all these different apps?
Well, the strategy is to always
have a single source of truth.
And what do I mean by that?
Well, you don't want
to have to hand write
two different things.
You don't want to have your
API written in handwritten Dart
and then handwritten
in JavaScript.
Because then, what's going
to happen is somebody's
going to change one and then
forget to change the other,
and you're going
to have this hidden
bug that you're
never going to find.
And this pattern comes up a
lot for this single source
of truth, for configurations,
for APIs, stuff like that.
So let's take an example.
AdWords API.
As you can imagine, we want to
use as many people as possible
to use AdWords API
as they would like.
It's 100,000 lines of code.
And this is just
four interfaces.
I'm not talking about the
limitation of the AdWords API
at all, just the API itself.
And there's 34 services
that people can use.
And we ourselves
use this service.
We dogfood our own API.
So the APIs that
developers are using
are the APIs that
we use ourselves.
Now we want to
allow any developer
to be able to write using
this API as possible.
It makes Google money.
AdWords API makes us money.
So any [INAUDIBLE] language
the developer wants to use,
we want to support if we can.
So there's six total
client languages
that we have, and we'd be crazy
to write 100,000 lines of code
six times.
It's just not going to happen.
So how do we do this?
Well, we generate our API.
We have one consistent API,
and we generate everything else
from that in all
the other languages.
So having a single
source of truth.
So let's do a very simple
example for a configuration.
At Google, we love protobuffers.
We use them all over the place.
So we have a very
simple protobuffer.
It's a rainbow that has
the number of colors
that it could have.
From this, we can generate
the Java code very simply.
It has its getters and setters.
And we can generate
the Dart code.
And protobufs support
some other languages, too.
So we have the one
single source of truth,
which is the protobuf,
and from that
we can generate the language
independent versions that we
need.
And you can generate this
using the dart-protoc-plugin.
OK, that's great.
You could use protobufs
for configuration.
You can use Yammer for
configuration, anything
that supports
multiple languages,
and you can get
along fine there.
But what about your API?
Well, you could use protobufs.
You could use JSON.
You could also use
Google Cloud Endpoints.
That supports many
different languages.
Or you could use Thrift or
a similar system to do this.
So here's a very simple example.
Let's say we want to send those
rainbow objects to our server.
Luckily for us, in Dart,
it's really, really easy.
You have a URL to the
endpoint of your service,
and then you can actually just
post on a request to JSON,
and protobuffers actually
have JSON support built in.
You also could do it in
binary, but we found out
the JSON was way
faster than binary
so that's why we
chose that direction.
PAUL ROHDE: Cool.
So we can generate stuff.
We can do things.
We can break apart
our application.
But that doesn't
really mean anything
unless we can actually
make sure it's still works.
I mean, you want it
to be able to work
one day, the next day,
and the day after.
And we've seen some pretty
bad examples of code
that failed that was
not very well tested.
I think that there
should be ways
that we should be able to ensure
that a code continues to work
and that it actually works
the way you intend it to,
which is really.
Important
So how are we going to do that?
TED SANDER: Yeah,
so this problem even
goes farther than that.
The landscape we
live in, everything's
moving really, really fast.
The Angular team,
we use Angular.
Angular's making changes
to improve their system
every single day,
every single week.
Polymer.
Polymer's actually
a moving target.
A lot of these are in spec,
but they change things
and make things different every
single day, every single week.
So you have the
libraries, the whole Earth
is shaking under
you and changing.
How do you make sure that
all that's working, too?
It's a big problem.
And the only way that
we've had to solve this
was test coverage.
Test coverage is key.
So what do I mean
by test coverage?
That means how much of
your production code
is covered by tests?
How much unit tests, how
many integration tests,
How many UI tests do you have?
Luckily, all the languages
we chose and stuff like that
make it really easy to do.
And at Google, we
have an idea, and that
is the idea of test sizes.
Not all tests are created equal.
So there's three
different versions
that we have at
Google, and we like
to categorize them as this.
And one is small test.
Small tests run
very, very quickly,
less than 100 milliseconds.
Mostly they're unit tests
and that kind of level,
and we'll talk a little
bit about what that is.
Then we have medium tests.
Medium tests execute
in about a second,
and these are UI tests,
integration tests,
things that still
run pretty quickly,
but they're a little
bit more complex.
Then we have large tests.
These things can take
up to 15 minutes.
They're insane.
We have full stack tests, maybe
they're performance tests,
and largely they're
automated tests.
So what are these?
These are the web
browser is actually
running to input the
code on your web page.
So you actually see the
text being filled out.
You see the select
boxes being chosen.
It makes you feel really
good because your web page is
actually working, and that's
the way the test is working.
So it gives you a
security blanket,
but they're so long to run,
they're actually not that good.
So here's what your desired test
coverage you want it to look
like.
You want to have about 10%
covered by large tests.
You don't want to
use them too often.
You want to maybe
have a smoke test
or a stress test,
something like that,
just to make sure
everything's still working.
Medium tests,
those are UI tests.
UIs usually you have
a little bit more
of these because they
take a little bit longer
to run because you need a
browser and interact with DOM.
And then you have
your small tests.
So medium tests, you want about
50% coverage, and small tests,
you want about 70% coverage.
And if you're going to have
more coverage on small tests,
then that's good.
Small tests are just the
unit tests like I said.
But this was our problem.
This is what our test
coverage looked like.
We had all of these large tests.
Our tests sometimes took hours
to run on our application.
Because we felt really good
with these automated tests.
We could see that
everything was working.
It was actually running
our application fully,
and it made us feel really
good inside to see it working.
But it made the tests
what we call flaky,
and what does flaky mean?
Flaky means that you had
the test errored out,
and the test didn't work.
It failed, but really if you run
it again, it's going to pass.
There's nothing to make that
test fail in the actual code.
It's just because it
took too long to run.
It timed out,
something like that.
And then we had this
problem with medium tests.
Medium tests, UI
tests, got a bad rap.
They were hard to write.
There were some
problem with them,
and everybody was like, Oh,
I don't want to write them.
I'll just write an
automated test instead.
And it created this
huge problem that we
couldn't rely on our tests.
They would fail all
the time for no reason,
and you were just like,
oh well, the build's red,
but that's probably just because
it's going to work next time.
I won't worry about it.
So how did we fix this?
Well, luckily, the tools
that we decided to use
make it really easy, and there
were some philosophy changes,
too.
So one thing is quickly,
what do the unit
tests look like in Dart?
Well, it's really easy to write.
You want to keep
it really simple.
You want to have one action,
and for that one action,
you want to make
sure that it has
the expected value
that you expect.
You want to try to only test
very little things if you can.
Don't have a unit
test that tries
to cover like every
single inspection
that you want in
that one unit test.
Why?
Because the next developer
that comes along,
he won't know if it's failing
because one specific thing
or it's failing 3/4 because
of something specific.
If you make it really specific,
then they can look at the title
and hopefully go, oh, I don't
even need to look at the code.
I can figure out exactly
why this is breaking.
So another problem that we
had was asynchronous testing.
Asynchronous
testing was actually
really hard in our old
system, but luckily Dart
makes it a little easier.
But Angular makes it
very easy, and I'll even
use asynchronous testing
using Dart Angular
without needing Angular at all.
So what do I mean by this?
Well, Angular turns
asynch testing
into synchronous testing,
which is awesome.
They like to call
it time travel.
They actually control the clock.
So if we look at
our little example,
there's a future in
there, and that future
is not going to be run right
away when it's declared.
It's going to be run
later at some time.
In the Dart regular unit
test, you just kind of say
that there'll be a future later.
And you can hook onto it,
and it will eventually
allow you to test it.
But using Angular,
as you can see,
at first, it's a false value.
But then you give up
your rendering loop,
and you say, oh, please do
whatever you need to do.
Please leap forward into time.
And then the future's
actually run,
and we can actually make
sure that the value's
what we expect.
Turning asynchronous testing
into synchronous testing.
Super powerful,
made it less flaky.
OK, UI tests.
Here's another problem.
We didn't like writing UI
tests, They were hard for us.
Again, Angular to the rescue.
So there's a way to easily
have testbed, which sets up
your Angular components
and directives.
And then you can actually pull
out the Angular object itself
and then play with
the Angular object,
rather than using
DOM manipulation
or sending DOM event somewhere,
doing something kind of crazy
like that.
You can actually test the
higher level object, which
makes it very easy, yet at the
same time, you have the HTML.
So you can quickly make
a little snippet of HTML
and start testing things nicely.
OK, so we have this
problem at Google
that since all these
other teams are working
on completely
separate things, how
can you make sure that
the team next to you
didn't change their
interface or make something
that's going to break you?
And I have a great
example for this.
And that's in 1999,
there was this project,
and it was called
the Mars Orbital.
And the Mars Orbital
gave out the project
to a couple different
government contractors,
and the systems, in
separation, worked great.
Each government
contractor tested it,
and it worked awesome.
But it turned out one
government contractor
was using English units.
They used feet.
And the other
government contractor
decided to use metric
like the rest of the world
does, but NASA doesn't
use metric, by the way.
They use English.
So when this is actually
going up to Mars,
when it was about to orbit
Mars, the systems freaked out
because one was telling
it the feet value,
and the other one
was expecting metric.
So it thought it was going
to crash land into Mars.
So it bailed.
It's like, Oh, I'm out of here.
We got to make sure
this doesn't happen.
I don't want to
crash land into Mars.
And actually sling
shot right past it.
$100 million mistake
that could have
been solved with
integration testing.
And this happens for us, too.
You have maybe a library
that you don't quite rely on
or it's a little sketchy,
but you need to use it.
Maybe you're worried
about them changing
their interface,
something like that.
And you want to
test the integration
between your pieces.
Or for us, we have those
integration points.
We split up all the apps.
We need to make sure that if
somebody changes one interface,
that it's not going to break
some other application.
And so here's a really
simple interface,
simple way to test two widgets.
I just came from Brazil,
and one of the problems
that I had there is
every time I tried
to enter my information
into an airline form
or whatever it might
be, Brazil actually
has different telephone input.
So here's an
example of something
where you could have one, which
is the country selector, which
allows you to select
which country you're from,
and the other's the
telephone input.
So when you choose Brazil,
the telephone input
should change and should give
you the right input for Brazil.
If you have the
US, then it should
be the right input
for the US, You
don't need to fully test
each widget in this test.
You just want to make
sure that that interaction
between the two is working
in the way that you expect.
OK, and lastly, we are
always testing at Google.
And luckily, it's not
QA testing because I
wouldn't get any work done.
It's not me clicking buttons
because that wouldn't be fun,
and honestly, I probably
wouldn't find too many bugs.
But we are always testing.
Our cloud is always
testing our code.
So what do I mean by this?
Well, every time before
we check in any code,
we make sure it works
on our code base.
Any time any other team
checks in the code,
like Angular or Polymer, we
make sure that that code works.
And we've got our
own tools to do this,
but you, too, can do
something like this.
And here's an example of it.
It's Travis.
Travis and Jenkins are two
good tools that you could use,
and the Angular Dart
project actually
uses it externally for GitHub
so you could check their page
to make sure that they're
working correctly,
and make sure everything
works well there.
So Paul, like I said before,
we had this problem of there's
so much DOM.
We had this div soup, and
writing front ends was hard.
I was like five
levels above the DOM.
I didn't even know what
it looked like anymore.
How are we going to
fix that problem?
PAUL ROHDE: Yeah,
it's a hard problem.
When I first started,
our front ends,
they would take 15 to
20 minutes to compile.
So I would go, and I would sit
down and I'd make a change,
and then I would go play
Candy Crush for a little while
and wait for my code to compile.
Then I would go back
and actually see
what actually happened.
And this is terrible, waiting
that long for something
to compile.
There's just no way that that's
going to make me productive.
Some applications were
a little bit worse.
Some were a little bit better.
But having the compile time
that just took that long
to actually see a
change, your mind
just does this mental
context switch.
And you have to go back.
You have to remember
what you were doing,
what you changed
why you changed it.
And it also means you end
up coding really badly.
You end up sitting down and
writing like 120 lines of code
because you don't want
to wait for the compile,
and you just hit Go, and
I hope that was right.
So this was one problem.
So as we started looking
forward and saying, OK,
what do we want to do next?
This was one of the problems
we wanted to address.
We wanted front end
developers to be productive,
to make a change and
instantly see it happen.
So that was one problem.
The other problem was we got
really far away from the DOM.
Now back about five years ago or
so, this was really important.
Like how many of you
remember seeing polyfills
make rounded corners
on buttons and things?
Or how many times did you
try to align stuff with CSS,
but it didn't work?
But it worked in one browser,
and then another browser
didn't work.
So we got farther away from
the DOM for good reason
because the browsers weren't
able to be consistent.
So now the browsers are tested.
Now they all work fairly well,
and the alignment usually
works most of the
way you expect it to.
But I still have this problem.
Because I was using
frameworks that
were farther away
from the DOM, I
could build something in the
prototype in a couple of days.
I'm usually pretty
good with CSS.
I'm pretty good with HTML.
I could throw something
together and make it
all work and function basically
the way that I wanted it to.
But then I would
take that prototype,
and then I wanted to actually
build it in a production code.
Now obviously there's going
to be some amount of overhead
to do this because there's all
the [? edge kiss ?] you have
to account for and
things like that.
But if it took me
two days to build it,
it would take me two
weeks to actually--
even longer, even a
month-- to actually build
a final version of
whatever I wanted to build.
And this just killed my joy
of actually building stuff.
So as we went
forward and we wanted
to do something
different, we started
looking at what can we do
to get closer to the DOM,
and what can we do to solve
some of these problems?
So the strategy was, we
don't want to fight the HTML.
HTML's gotten a lot better.
You've gotten a lot
closer to the DOM.
We've seen all the cool stuff
that Polymer's been doing.
You want to get
closer to the DOM
so that when you're
writing applications,
you're not writing this big,
vague abstract sense of like,
I need a thing.
You want to extend it.
You want to make the
DOM more powerful.
So we picked up
AngularDart, which
is, you guys should
have all heard
about Angular at
this point in time.
But Angular has two flavors now.
They've got a Dart
flavor and a JS flavor.
We'll talk about Dart
in the last section,
but I want to talk about
Angular really quick.
It has a lot of the very
same underlying constructs
as Polymer, and it
gives you behaviors.
This idea that you
want very simple things
that you can then
bind into your model.
This is really powerful because
it gets you close to the HTML.
You can write your
page, and then you
can add little
behaviors to the HTML
that you've already written.
This is really useful because
we have like prototypers that
would go, we'd have a mock that
would be built up, and hey,
you want to build this?
And then they come in and
someone would build the HTML,
and then I'm now
able as an engineer
to take that and just extend
it and fill in all the missing
pieces.
So what does it look
like to have behaviors?
Angular has some very simple
things, like ng-repeat.
They're very simple.
It does one thing.
It takes a piece of
DOM, and it stamps it
out over and over again.
And it lets you have a
model that is discrete.
Now this is really
useful when you're
trying to test things, when
you're trying to build business
logic, and you want to make
sure that your code actually
does what you expect it to
do without adding timers,
without adding DOM
manipulation, without adding
all this extra
fluff to your code.
All you want to do is want to
say, I have a list of people,
and I want to add a new person.
You don't want to say, I want
to keep a mapping of person
to DOM element, and then when I
add it, I now create a new one.
And then I append it.
And did I append it
in the right place?
Did I not append it
Now I want to remove this one
so now I have to go to the DOM,
and I have to remove it.
You just want to have
a list of people,
and you want to
say, Add and Remove.
And Angular let's you do this.
The other example I
give is ng-if, but only
because with these
two behaviors,
you can now compose
things together.
This is what becomes really,
really powerful is this idea
that you have these simple
behaviors like gears
that you can then take
and you can put together.
And you can compose
repeats with ifs,
and you can build a
huge, very functional UI
in a very short amount of
time that's very solid.
And that's what you
wanted, and this
is part of the reason
why we picked this,
this whole idea that you want
simple things that you can then
compose together.
A gear is very, very
simple, but a clock is easy.
Now when you're
building application,
you need lots and
lots of simple pieces,
and it's important to
realize the difference
between simple and easy.
Simple you can compose together
very easily without effort.
You can't reduce it any farther.
With ng-repeat,
for instance, you
can't take away anything
from the actual behavior.
If you took it away, it wouldn't
actually be a repeat anymore.
Same thing with if.
It's about as simple as
you can possibly make it.
A clock, on the
other hand, is great.
It's very self-contained, and
it has a really good usage.
But it's one of
those things where
it's the final
state of something.
You can't take a clock and
compose it with another clock.
You have to rip it apart
and take all the gears out.
And then you can
build the dual clock.
But there's a lot
of work involved
in ripping it apart and
putting it back together.
It may be easy
because it tells time,
and you can wind it and change
it, but it's not simple.
And it's an important
distinction.
They're both good, but they
just have different purposes.
So you guys have seen lots of
Polymer component stuff today,
and Angular is built
on the same foundation.
It uses the same
underlying technologies.
It uses Shadow DOM.
It uses the web
component spec, and it
uses all these same
underlying technologies.
It just does it a
little bit differently.
Regardless of what
technology you use,
you want to have a story
for building components
to isolate things in your
page, especially when you
start talking about CSS.
CSS is the last remaining global
variable on your web pages.
You want to get rid of that
so that you can actually
have object-oriented programming
and apply it to your web pages
and not just as this global
thing that styles everything.
So this is really
useful, and we've
seen this be really useful.
This is an example
of what it looks
like if you opened
up the inspector.
It's basically a
bunch of elements
that exist behind
the actual element,
and it lets you scope things.
So your style element
doesn't leak outwards.
It doesn't leak down.
And it prevents this mess
when you build really
big applications.
It's really easy for developers
to write styles that step
on each other.
I don't know how many of you
have ever written web pages,
but have you ever seen
somebody write a paragraph tag
with a red important tag
and try to figure out
where that actually came from?
It's really hard,
and so this actually
gives you real scoping
that's just much better.
And that's really powerful.
TED SANDER: So that's great.
I mean, we seem to have
a story figured out
to make it better for developers
to write HTML and be closer
to what the actual designers are
making and that kind of stuff.
But how in the
world are we going
to make sure that
this works for 100
engineers, a million
lines of code?
How are we going
to make sure it's
going to scale every
single time we use it,
and that five years
down the road,
we're not deciding
to do something else?
PAUL ROHDE: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I mean, like you said, we have
lots and lots of engineers.
We have huge code bases.
And we want to be able to
build these huge front ends,
and we want to
build them quickly.
And then once we
build them, we want
to be able to change
them because that's
how you build business.
You build something.
You take it.
You iterate on it.
So we picked up on Dart.
We loved a lot of things
about the language itself.
But mostly, it was able
to take what we have,
and we were able to tie it
into one cohesive tool set.
So instead of having a
mishmash of one thing,
another thing, two libraries
here, one library here,
a different language
underneath JavaScript,
we wanted to build
a stack that we
could have a very
clean, well-defined way
to build front ends that worked
for a lot of different people.
And we wanted to
have a cohesive story
of how you can build
a front end quickly
and how you can continue to
scale that from one or two
engineers all the way
up to 100 to 200 to 300.
So we wanted these tools, and
we wanted to be able to do this.
And we picked up on Dart, and
I'll explain in just a second.
So like I said, Dart has a lot
of different things about it.
It's batteries included.
It has all the different
pieces that we needed,
and I'll show you why.
The first thing that we wanted
is we wanted it to be fast.
And this is a big huge
selling point for us.
We wanted our front ends to
run just as fast as JavaScript.
Because if it wasn't
going to be fast enough,
why not just do
JavaScript, right?
Because we have to run
it in JavaScript anyways.
So even Dart it compiles a JS,
and it runs just as fast as JS.
It's fast, and it also has
a bunch of other things
that we liked about it, too.
So Dart is fast, and my slides
will eventually keep up.
Yes, there we go.
In a lot of benchmarks,
specifically, you
can go on the Dart web page,
and you can go look these up.
There's a bunch of benchmarks,
and what we really cared about
was Dart to JS because
even though Chrome
may be coming along and
iterating really fast,
we still knew that we
had to run a JavaScript
at least for a good
amount of time.
And a lot of browsers
were not ever going
to adopt any sort of engine
other than JavaScript.
So that was a core
requirement was
that it had to be just
as fast as JavaScript.
And it is.
And it gives us a lot
of other things as well,
beyond just JavaScript.
The biggest one is types.
I don't know how many of
you tried to grip a file
to replace a string
in JavaScript,
but you have no idea if
it actually worked or not.
We wanted to be able
to do refactoring.
We have large teams of
people, and you want your code
to be readable, but you also
want it to be refactorable.
You want to be able
to take a class,
remove it, change it, modify
it, rename things, and know
that when you change
it, it's going
to change in all the places
you actually care about.
If you don't, then you
end up in this soup
of trying to figure out
exactly why this method exists
sometimes and not other times.
And we didn't want that.
And so Dart gives us types.
It also makes it so it can
optimize the JS faster.
And we can do that some with
closure in JavaScript, too,
but just having built-in
support was really nice.
As an example, not only
does it give you types,
but it's still dynamic.
It still lets you do all
those JavaScript-y things.
As an example here,
this is the same method
with types and without types.
So you still get
all the flexibility
that you have with
JavaScript, but by default you
want to put in
types, but you don't
have to if you don't need to.
Or if you have a case where
you really don't want to
and you want to jump into
more Javascript-y type things.
And this is really
important as we
build web front ends
because a lot of times
you run into these cases where
you want to build things,
either statically
and dynamically.
So gave this to us.
Next, Dart gave us
a package manager.
It's really hard to
manage dependencies
if you don't have a good
system for managing it.
Now you might have
a good system,
but if you don't have a
consistent system that's
shared between a whole
bunch of different things,
that's really hard to deal with.
Do you pick require JS?
Do you pick a whole bunch of
different package managers?
Do you use node?
What do you use to
manage code dependencies?
So Dart, again with this whole
theme of there's batteries
included, it gives
you a package manager
that can let you manage all
the dependencies of your code.
And this is really,
really powerful
because then you don't have
to fight over which package
manager you're actually using.
And if you use a
different library that
happens to use
something different,
you're not restricted
because of that.
So that was really
important for us.
I have an example up here if
what it actually looks like.
The pubspec.yaml was basically
just a configuration file.
You don't have to pay
too much attention to it.
But it lets you specify
the dependencies.
It's all pulled through pub.
It's got a central ecosystem.
And you can get new
ones, either pub get,
and pub upgrade lets you
upgrade existing dependencies
and things like that.
But it's just a simple
dependency management system,
but it's baked into
the language and it's
part of the whole ecosystem
that comes with it.
We picked Dart not just
because of the language,
but because of the ecosystem.
So that's about all we
got for you guys today.
Hopefully, that was at
least useful to at least see
some of what we do
at Google and see
what it's like for
engineers to come up
and actually speak and
share a little bit of what
we do every day.
I'm Paul Rohde.
This is Ted Sanders.
We'll be around a little
bit to answer questions
if you want to come
up to the stage,
and we'll talk to you later.
But that's all we
got for you guys.
Thank you.